Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
C'est l'histoire d'un homme qui tombe
d'un immeuble de 50 étages.
Le mec, au fur et à mesure de sa chute,
il se répète sans cesse pour se rassurer :
« Jusqu’ici tout va bien.
Jusqu'ici tout va bien.
Jusqu’ici tout va bien. »
Mais l’important, ce n’est pas la chute,
c’est l’atterrissage.
Je m’appelle Matthias Baccino
et aujourd’hui je vais vous parler d’un
sujet tabou par excellence : l’argent.
Un murmure dans la salle,
j’ai presque honte en le disant.
Je vais vous dire pourquoi
je milite activement
en faveur de l’indépendance
financière pour tous
et comment nous pouvons, collectivement,
reprendre le pouvoir sur l’argent.
Ça part d’une idée simple :
nous travaillons pour gagner de l’argent.
Et si on pouvait aussi faire en sorte
que notre argent travaille
pour nous tous ?
L'argent au service de l'homme
et pas l'inverse.
Ce changement de modèle, c’est ce
que j’appelle la transition financière.
Pourquoi c’est important ? Pourquoi
je suis venu pour vous en parler ?
Parce que nous voyons tous -
On n’a pas forcément
les compétences techniques pour,
mais on en a tous l'intuition.
Le bon sens.
On voit tous les conditions
macro-économiques se dégrader
de manière structurelle.
Les dettes des États massives,
le vieillissement de la population,
bonne nouvelle à l’échelle individuelle
mais qui met en difficulté
nos solidarités.
Et l’argent qui dort,
ou plutôt qui meurt à petit feu
face à l’inflation qui explose.
Voilà trois moteurs d’un phénomène :
celui de l’appauvrissement programmé
de la population européenne
dans les 20 ans qui viennent.
Mais jusqu’ici,
tout va bien.
Le problème, ce n’est pas la chute,
c’est l’atterrissage.
Et l’atterrissage,
si, collectivement, nous ne voulons pas
qu’il soit trop brutal,
il va nous falloir changer.
Et pour changer,
il va nous falloir lutter.
Lutter contre nos habitudes,
nos conservatismes.
Lutter aussi contre les intérêts
financiers et économiques des banques,
des assureurs, du système financier.
Mais peut-être aussi et surtout,
il va nous falloir lutter
contre nos freins psychologiques,
notre propre psychologie,
nos propres peurs face à l’épargne,
face à l’investissement
et plus largement face à l'argent.
Moi, je crois que le jeu
en vaut la chandelle.
Je crois que ça vaut le coup de lutter
parce que je crois que
cette question collective,
la manière avec laquelle
nous gérons notre argent,
est la question de société
la plus importante
à laquelle nous ayons à faire face
dans les années qui viennent,
après la protection
de notre environnement.
Ça, c'est important.
En un mot,
je crois qu’être capable
aujourd’hui individuellement,
de gérer notre argent et de l’investir,
aujourd’hui, c’est une clé indispensable
si l’on veut un monde plus juste demain.
Allez, on en parle.
Pourquoi je me suis intéressé
à la question de l’argent
au point d’en faire ma profession ?
C'est vrai que c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser.
Et je suis issu d’une famille -
comme certainement beaucoup d’entre vous -
d’une famille populaire,
d’une famille immigrée.
Une famille qui a tout construit
à partir de rien,
comme énormément d’entre nous,
qui a beaucoup travaillé.
Certaines générations ont eu deux jobs
pour pouvoir payer les études des enfants,
d’autres ont contracté des crédits.
Parfois trop.
Au travers de mon histoire familiale,
j’ai aussi connu le surendettement,
les huissiers.
Quand j’étais étudiant,
comme beaucoup d’entre nous,
j’ai contracté un crédit sans apport.
Et là, il s’est passé quelque chose
d’important :
j’ai eu peur.
J'ai eu peur de reproduire.
J'ai eu peur de ne pas réussir
à m'en extraire.
J’ai eu peur
de manquer, peur de l’argent,
manque de contrôle.
C'est fou quand on y pense, l'impact que
cette peur de l'argent a eu dans ma vie,
puisque j’en ai même décidé
d’en faire mon métier,
de travailler dans le secteur financier,
probablement pour m’en protéger.
Et le secteur financier, plus je
l’ai découvert, plus je l’ai quitté.
Et aujourd'hui, j'essaye
de le transformer.
Le problème, ce n’est pas
que j’ai eu peur ;
le problème, c’est que
je ne suis pas le seul.
Aujourd’hui, plus de la moitié
des Européens ont peur,
dans leurs tripes, ont peur -
c’est un mot fort,
on va en parler tout à l’heure -
pour leur avenir financier.
Plus de la moitié des Européens.
Comment peut-on l’accepter ?
En même temps, on les comprend.
Parce que quand on prend
un peu de recul, qu’on dézoome,
et qu’on regarde objectivement les
conditions socio-économiques actuelles,
collectivement,
qu’est-ce qu’on voit ?
Que les placements préférés des Français,
le livret A, le fonds en euros,
l’assurance vie,
font perdre de l’argent
aux gens tous les mois.
Parce que l’inflation est de retour.
En 2021, en un an,
dans un seul pays européen, la France,
nous avons brûlé sur les comptes courants,
les livrets A,
collectivement, et plutôt les classes
moyennes et classes populaires,
45 milliardsd'euros face à l'inflation.
Je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais moi, il me semble
que c’est un gaspillage
qu’on ne peut plus se permettre.
Mais qui s’en occupe ?
Deuxième observation,
ce phénomène est pan-européen :
85% de l’épargne des Européens est investi
sur des produits qui ne rapportent rien,
c’est-à-dire que l’argent ne dort pas,
il meurt petit à petit.
On voit aussi
que 10 à 15% de la population européenne
a reçu une éducation financière.
Par la famille, principalement
les catégories aisées.
C'est un vrai déterminisme social.
Encore aujourd’hui, en 2022.
Ça doit changer.
Mais qui s’en occupe ?
Tout ça nous mène à un constat
qui est celui de la baisse,
probable à partir de 2040,
mais très significative,
des pensions de retraite.
Une perte de 40% de pouvoir d'achat pour
les futurs retraités à partir de 2040.
Et qui s’en occupe ?
Alors si personne ne s’en occupe,
le problème, ce ne sera pas la chute,
ce sera l’atterrissage
Et l’atterrissage,
ce sera que les grands-parents de demain
ne pourront plus aider financièrement
leurs enfants et leurs petits-enfants.
Alors,
on s’en occupe ?
On essaye.
Par notre travail,
par notre consommation,
par notre activité,
nous contribuons tous
à la croissance économique.
Nous contribuons tous
à la création de valeur.
Pourtant, seuls 15% de la population
à peu près en touche les fruits.
Ne peut-on pas imaginer une société
dans laquelle nous toucherions tous
les fruits de la croissance économique,
dans laquelle nous aurions repris
le contrôle sur notre argent ?
C’est ça ce que j’appelle
la transition financière.
Et tout le monde en est capable.
C’est ce dont je suis venu vous parler,
essayer de vous donner confiance,
en vous-même et en votre capacité,
malgré ce que l’on vous a dit,
à gérer vous-même votre argent.
Quand j’investis,
en général, j’investis
dans des entreprises,
des secteurs de l’économie, des secteurs
d’activité, pourquoi pas des pays ?
auxquels je crois,
des entreprises que j’aime,
à nouveau des secteurs d’activité.
Ça, c’est avoir un impact direct
sur la vie économique collective, puisque,
quand on est actionnaire par exemple -
propriétaire aussi,
mais actionnaire,
on peut exercer son droit de vote -
on peut avoir un impact sur le
comportement écologique des entreprises.
On peut avoir un impact
sur la rémunération des dirigeants.
On peut avoir un impact sur les conditions
de travail des salariés.
On peut créer, grâce à l'investissement,
une société davantage participative,
davantage juste.
Ce que vous ne savez pas, c’est
qu’il suffit de maîtriser trois règles
pour commencer à investir efficacement.
Ce que vous ne savez pas non plus,
c’est que vous avez déjà
des idées d’investissement.
Vous avez suffisamment d’intuition
pour avoir des idées d’investissement.
Vous en doutez ?
Alors on va faire un petit test.
Qui dans cette salle possède un iPhone ?
Levez la main, s'il vous plaît.
OK.
Qui dans cette salle
est actionnaire d’Apple ?
Vous comprenez l’idée ?
Depuis que l’iPhone est sorti,
la valeur d’une action Apple
a été multipliée par huit.
En quinze ans.
Je pourrais faire la même chose
avec Amazon.
avec tant d’entreprises,
tant d’autres secteurs.
Investir dans une entreprise ou un secteur
d'activité qu'on aime, qu'on connaît,
c’est, quasiment dans 100% des cas,
le premier pas.
Ça a été mon cas.
Moi aussi, mon voyage d’investissement
a démarré comme ça en 2006,
lors d’un voyage en Asie centrale.
Je n’étais pas à vélo
mais néanmoins au Kirghizstan.
J’ai découvert à cette occasion
l’importance vitale de l’eau
et des entreprises qui s’occupent
du secteur de l’eau.
Alors j'ai commencé à investir
dans ce secteur.
Il est possible d’investir
dans un secteur directement,
dans ce qu’on appelle les ETF.
Ce sont des paniers d’actions
qui rassemblent toutes les actions
d’un secteur d’activité.
Ça facilite la diversification.
Moi, j'ai commencé comme ça.
Vous aussi, vous pouvez
commencer comme ça.
Parce que si vous ne le faites pas,
le problème, ce n’est pas la chute,
ce sera l’atterrissage.
Il suffit de trois règles.
On va parler de ces règles très
simplement ; il y en a trois à connaître.
Vous avez tous le permis de conduire.
On pense ne pas avoir les compétences pour
investir, je vais poser des questions.
En tant que hommes et femmes,
en tant que participant à la société,
on a le droit de voter, on a le droit
de construire des entreprises -
même construire des fusées.
On a le droit de faire
des enfants et de les élever.
On a le permis de conduire,
on a de l’éducation civique.
On a de l'éducation sportive.
Ce qu’on n’a pas,
c’est de l’éducation financière.
Je suis là pour ça : ces trois règles,
on aurait dû tous les apprendre à l’école.
L’enjeu, c’est de créer
une génération de citoyens investisseurs
capables de nous aider collectivement à
nous propulser dans le monde de demain.
La première règle,
c’est d’investir à long terme
et d’investir le plus tôt possible.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’investir, ce n’est pas spéculer.
La spéculation,
c’est essayer d’acheter au plus bas,
de vendre au plus haut
et de générer le plus vite possible
le plus fort rendement.
On appelle ça aussi du trading.
Ce n’est pas interdit,
mais c’est vachement dur.
Il y en a beaucoup qui ont essayé.
Ils ont eu des problèmes.
85 à 90% des gens qui essayent de faire
du trading hyperactif n'y arrivent pas.
Normal, c’est difficile ; par contre,
quand on investit à long terme,
on bénéficie d’un truc très très
beau dans l’investissement,
ce qu’on appelle la moyenne.
C’est rare que ce soit bien d’être moyen,
mais la moyenne des actions
du monde entier depuis 120 ans,
c'est 5% par an.
Le CAC40, que vous connaissez tous,
depuis sa création,
en moyenne, c’est 7% par an.
On investit à long terme
pour bénéficier de la moyenne.
Et pourquoi on commence
à investir tôt dans la vie ?
On n’a pas beaucoup d’argent
quand on est jeune.
Eh bien, même si on n’a pas beaucoup
d’argent, ça vaut le coup de commencer.
Pourquoi ?
C'est mathématique, c'est très simple.
Prenez deux personnes.
Une personne qui commence
à investir à 20 ans
et une qui commence à investir à 30 ans.
La même somme tous les mois.
A 60 ans, celui qui a commencé
à 20 ans a deux fois plus.
Ça s'appelle les intérêts composés.
C'est l'effet boule de neige.
Et ça, je pense que vous allez aller
regarder ce soir ce que c'est.
La deuxième règle qui est indispensable
pour commencer à investir,
toujours dans la logique de permis
d’investir que vous passez :
diversifier - on ne met pas
tous ses œufs dans le même panier.
Je n’ai pas fait Polytechnique
pour le savoir.
C’est du bon sens, vous le ressentez tous.
La bonne nouvelle est qu’aujourd’hui,
c’est plus facile de le faire.
Il n’est plus nécessaire d’aller acheter
un, deux, trois, plusieurs biens, etc.
On peut le faire beaucoup plus simplement.
Énormément de véhicules
ont été créés pour ça.
Diversifier.
Troisième règle, qui est
moins connue en France :
il faut investir
progressivement.
Ça n'est jamais le bon moment
pour tout investir.
C’est toujours le bon moment
pour commencer à investir,
parce qu’investir, ce n’est pas spéculer.
Quand on veut tout mettre,
c’est qu’on spécule,
qu’on essaye d’acheter au plus bas
pour vendre au plus haut.
Investir progressivement
un petit peu tous les mois,
ça permet tout simplement de diviser
par trois le risque que l’on prend.
Et ça permet aussi de multiplier par deux
sa probabilité, sa chance,
de gagner de l’argent à 20 ans
de manière significative.
Donc, investir de manière long termiste,
investir de manière diversifiée,
investir progressivement,
le plus jeune possible,
ça, ça fonctionne.
Ce n’est pas moi qui le dis, ce sont
les économistes, les mathématiciens.
Statistiquement, ça fonctionne.
Donc,
quatrième règle pour vous aider
à vous tenir aux trois premières.
Je vais faire un éloge de la passivité.
Ne regardez pas vos investissements
plus d'une fois par an.
Ça vous évitera
de répondre à vos biais psychologiques.
Ça vous évitera de prendre
des mauvaises décisions
et ça vous évitera
de trahir vos convictions
puisque si vous avez investi,
c’est que vous aviez une conviction.
Avec ces trois règles
et ce quatrième conseil,
avec votre curiosité,
avec les encouragements que
j’essaye de vous donner ce soir,
j’espère que demain, investir ne sera
plus pour vous une terre inconnue,
mais plutôt une routine,
une nouvelle habitude
pour faire travailler votre argent
à votre service, au service
de l’homme et de la société.
Parce que quand vous investissez,
vous investissez pour vous,
vous investissez pour vos proches,
vous investissez pour la société
dans son ensemble.
L’industrie de la gestion financière
est devenue très créative.
Aujourd’hui. de l’art au vin
en passant par les NFT,
en passant par les actions
du monde entier,
les ETF,
le sport,
on a tous une possibilité d’investir
dans quelque chose auquel on croit,
dans quelque chose qui nous ressemble.
La bonne nouvelle pour terminer
sur une note d’espoir positive,
c’est que, quand je vous ai dit tout à
l’heure que personne ne s’en occupait,
je ne vous ai pas tout à fait
dit la vérité.
Et ceux qui s’en occupent de ce problème,
depuis deux ans,
massivement,
ce sont les jeunes.
Avec l’arrivée des crypto,
avec la pandémie de coronavirus,
la jeunesse s’est intéressée
à l’investissement
et s’est forgée, entre autres
sur les réseaux sociaux,
grâce aux créateurs de contenus,
une solide culture financière.
C’est la 1e fois que des centaines de
milliers de jeunes se mettent à investir.
Et contrairement à ce que
peuvent refléter les médias,
ces jeunes ne spéculent pas.
Ils investissent à long terme
car ils ont compris,
grâce aux réseaux sociaux,
la situation dans laquelle nous étions.
C’est la première fois que
les lignes bougent comme ça.
C'est une note d'espoir considérable.
Alors,
n’ayons pas peur.
Reprenons le contrôle sur l'argent.
Remettons l’argent à sa juste place,
celle d’un outil au service de l’homme,
au service de la société,
et peut-être au service d’un monde
qui nous ressemblera davantage.
Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)